the word community sounds odd and a bit
disparity some pretty negative images
tend to come to mind when we think about
what other people are like without quite
realizing it we drawn images fed to us
by the media and that's why we tend to
think that most people are pretty
violent driven by success and fame and
not necessarily very pleasant it breeds
an urge to stay at home and make private
life for the center of things we
associate happiness with standing out
from the crowd with personal happiness
the nuclear family and business success
community feels like it's for losers the
individual is king
there are some weird moments a big
sporting event an election day extreme
weather like a big snowfall and we might
make a discovery as basic as it's
absolutely crucial most people are very
nice they're interested in small things
they're mild and moderate they're funny
they're kind they want to help
despite some surface differences they're
like you a painfully exciting idea comes
to mind if we could more regularly
generate communal moments meet people
hang out in groups we wouldn't have to
imagine that the whole world was so
competitive and so dangerous we wouldn't
have to be so guarded closed off
suspicious we wouldn't be so focused on
our own love lives and all their issues
we've allowed our worldview to be
kidnapped by the media by narcissists
and sociopaths we've allowed our sense
of what's normal to be shaped by
newspapers and television stations that
make money from creating imaginary
communities of monsters and pointing out
everything that's wrong and to be scared
off we've allowed the kinder elements to
seem like they're the exceptions when
it's in fact for bad that's the
exception it's time to change what
happens on those special occasions is
the truth other people aren't strange or
so different we can trust in community
of course we need some special occasions
some encouragement to come out of
ourselves we're still too shy at the
moment we only know how to do it around
sport or the odd other occasion but we
should more regularly come together and
learn how to do so we should ensure that
the nicest buildings in every
neighborhood are the community centers
there's a huge part of us that longs to
live more collectively it's hugely
beneficial to be able to feel
enthusiastic and committed to one's
whole society
to feel reassured by membership of an
admirable community collective pride
takes the burden of self regard of the
individual ego we don't have to do it
all ourselves we can belong to something
better and sometimes greater than we are
you